at the opportunity a couple of days ago
to sit down with Kevin Costner and of
course Bull Durham JFK The Untouchables
Field of Dreams and he came into the New
York City man cave and we talked about a
variety of things but we started the
interview with a bit of an awkward
greeting to one another great SIA
looking good we did have I don't know if
it was an awkward moment but I wasn't
sure if I was supposed to maybe give you
a handshake or I was going to give you a
hug or handshake hug do you understand
what they yeah I understand that there's
a lot of greetings out there these days
and and and it you know the perfect
examples are on television but I don't
know I stuck my hand out and and I got a
feeling like you're a handshake guy too
and you just have to kind of go along
with this this club that's ever going
but I deal with young athletes you know
and they it's they're not doing a firm
handshake know so I got to do like a hug
and then they bring you in and then pat
you on the back a couple times a good
start it's not a good start but uh you
know you got once you get by whatever
it's gonna be what you hold though yeah
maybe that's what it is I don't know
yeah good good point are we told Jesus
Christ I am you think you're not hey
what sport could you play right now that
you would actually feel comfortable
doing well you know I can't play
basketball anymore and I really reason I
say that is because I can't guard
anybody because of the knees and if you
can't guard somebody you can't say you
play basketball we'll go out and shoot
wait a minute wait you just took a shot
at me though I even when I knees were
good yeah I didn't garden well you get
well you maybe didn't garden but you
tried to garden but that's how kind of I
did I got you now I can just shoot shoot
around it go you play basketball no I
don't because you shoot yes yeah you
sure you don't do don't do the other
stuff but you know I the the knees have
taken it away but if you look at when
you play baseball with Bull Durham or
its tin cup like which one do you look
at because trying to convince people
that you could do this or your real
is as part of the battle I think when it
comes to sports that the audience
believes that you're capable because the
rasa yeah you have to make that up in
your mind I mean either have respect for
sport or not and and and and you know
you know even Olivia if he couldn't play
but he might been the greatest actor
ever but if you can't hit a ball you
can't out act it there's a one thing in
movies you can't do and so like I would
never do a hockey move because I don't
know how to skate and there's so many
people that think they can automatically
play sports and even a non-athlete
can recognize in a second somebody who
can't play and it bothers me it bothers
you at by everybody in the room you say
man you know you there's a motion
there's a ballet move that is so obvious
and it's the little things that even
come in between swinging the bat it's
just how you move
did you believe Redford when he played
bass he can play a little bit but he's
athletic he's coordinated you could see
it you know and so yeah though he had
the moves what's the movie sports movie
that hasn't been told yet that I don't
know if there is one that you have you
know I had this thought about a you know
a basketball you know coach idea where
you know he's just getting beat the hell
out of the color announcer who wants his
job the you know the everybody the
town's after him that I can't get the
athletes to play and then and then the
owner brings in some girl that was on
Time magazine because she turns
companies around psychologically and he
thinks my team sucks and she brings her
in and so it's I you just have the whole
town bearing down on you and now I've
got a psychologist in I mean I was
thinking what we called it basket cases
but we never wrote it but I don't know
they're hard to do they're like Western
sports movies that people think that
there's black hat white hat that just
should be pretty easy thinking like
sports oh that's a great story but the
reality is a great story doesn't make a
great movie a great script does and the
distilling a story down to the way
Shelton did a guy ironing clothes and
the broad comes in and really
understanding that and under
standing that a guy's willing to go hit
a homerun in obscurity just because the
even though he knows it's a book record
in a way because it's minor leak and I
never find himself talking about devar
he he elects to still room with an 18
year old and he goes and he hits that
last home run because it means something
to him and there's this level of poetry
that comes with sports inside all the
vulgarity and all the insanity that is
but you couldn't do a sequel where
crashes a manager in you and Susan I
could if I could have Ron if Ron wrapped
his arms around it and got it to that
point where he thought it was good and I
thought it was good I'll do a sequel it
hasn't been a part of my career makeup
yeah but if you can get to that second
movie and not you know a lot of times
now in movies you see these sequels and
then or the sequel comes after a movie
you maybe like and it's not very good
and then they kind of go you know we
really apologize for that second and
we're going to make a third one and you
just realize they're just back in that
truck in seeing how big a shovel they
can get and throwing the money yes oh
really but you could just think about
how many times you hear I apologize for
that second one you know what I it's
like really you know so it's a it's a
pretty good business the apology
business did you buy a new mannan
slapshot uh he could skate he could
skate yeah and you know Paul could
deliver a line and he played the elder
guy and you know but you know a peer
Jimmy Piersall story we didn't buy we
didn't buy them going up on the fence
and you see it and listen you can't
always get it perfect I mean we made a
pretty perfect movie and fill the trays
but Shoeless Joe is throws left yeah and
any any hits left and I knew I was going
to take the bullets for that you know
and I said to the director was really
wrote a piece of a lifetime you know I'm
I'm the one who's going to take a
beating for this like why didn't you
stop that you know what I mean from so
Ray Liotta is down did ray no to that
this is what should have been asked of
him to be huge go at a certain moment I
just didn't say any that that would that
would have just messed with him
in a real way but you know the treat on
that movie was working with Lancaster
burn I guess yeah
you know what I mean that this is the
guy that ran across that water in that
Kentucky and you know thought would well
through I actually said I actually said
we're sitting next to each other I said
you know that shot of rot across the
water because you saw that I said yeah
he was gonna tell you how I did it go
yeah and he said first huh
I ran through where the guy was shooting
and I told the director I'm gonna run as
fast as I can I want him to load and
when he's done loading I want you to
tell me to stop when I run that way I'll
know where I'm going to start and this
is where I'll be hiding and this is
where I'll go so you saw it was that's a
good imitation he was ride oh no how
good imitation was but what was really
maybe the best part of the imitation was
you saw that because he loved the
details of what he did and you know and
I said that fight with matha was amazing
you know that whip and that woman rolls
the thing over and it was like you know
we were suddenly the same animal on the
Serengeti him and I started talking you
know we had suddenly bridged that thing
that it was only him and I co-taught
he's Kevin Costner joining us here in
the man cave what people say on the
streets when you're in New York well the
good thing is I never know what they're
going to say when it comes to a movie
and I'm kind of glad my career hasn't
drilled down to a single movie if their
movies have a chance to to affect people
in different ways and so you know I
wrote eights between about 10 12 movies
that somebody will come up and say that
was my movie that was my movie and I
think I'm kind of happiest about that
but is there because you'd have to do
this retrospective it feels like when
people do interviews with you because
yeah i i'm curious about certain things
that you've done but also i what was
your life like at the peak of your
success the well i thought i was
happening before i was happening and
after i was happening i didn't think
much about it and now when you go what
let's go find that peak was it crazy
it wasn't crazy for me because it didn't
happen for me at 19 and 20 my first
check came in at about 28 years old so I
didn't have my
head out of a out of a limousine going
down sunset doing cocaine on the hood I
was like anxious to do my next movie
and when people said well your fifth
movie and you directed aren't you think
you're going a little fast I said man
I've been waiting a long time yeah I've
been watching I was a stage manager for
three years watching all the cameras
doing all this stuff making $3 and 24
cents an hour I think and I was watching
so for them it was like a fast jumpin
for me I had been moving that direction
all the time did you have acting heroes
or sports heroes I had both I really had
both but did you aspire to be an athlete
yeah first yeah I think I did yeah I you
know Brock was somebody that I Lou Brock
yeah was somebody that I really really
liked and how he played how he how he
hit and you know I've seen so many you
know when I see all this slow motion
stuff now that still makes guys in the
room cry makes me cry if that voice
comes up sable and all those different
peoples that would talk you know I think
I saw those games I mean I saw I saw Oh
Jay play Namath in a preseason game
because I wanted to see the Heisman
Trophy winner play against a Super Bowl
champion and you know there was only
like one game a week like I'm just a BS
and so I have watched the games
faithfully for 30 40 years it just I
just do what is uh is there a comparison
between being uh being an athlete being
an actor well I direct like a coach
sometimes when I'm doing an action scene
and you know and I start talking to the
guys I can see them start doing this
like you know there's a lot of these
shin boogie things yeah yeah yeah and
really it's not that they understand
they're actually nervous they're saying
quit talking to me don't talk today and
then when I do the scene and the bombs
go off or something goes off and I think
where were you man well I thought I go
what do you mean you were going like
this to me you were going like this to
me where were you now we've got to do
this all over again a long time ago I
just brought out a chalkboard
I said look you got to be here when it
says okay if I come here are you going
to come out no good when you see me
that's when you're coming out and I
found that with a chalkboard I can
actually get a lot done and but you mess
with an actor on a hot streak you know
there's the scene in Bull Durham you
know you don't mess with yeah somebody
on husky but if an actor is in the zone
you don't do you know it and don't talk
to him yeah you don't need to you know
you don't need to say anything unless
you feel like you have this pride of
authorship you know it's like when I had
the ball and you know I I knew the lines
would work for him and I didn't feel the
need to to say anything unless I needed
to move him somewhere and I never
hesitated with that but you know I mean
some guys really know how to turn a line
they just know how to do it um trying to
think you know when when you uh you get
you deep dive into sports but I think we
get confused that sports movies are
about sports when they're it's all about
a relationship yeah is it there the back
there the backdrop there the big there
the big thing is it without you and
Susan Sarandon and Bull Durham like that
relationship is what it's about it's not
about baseball yeah if it's about
baseball then it just becomes a
documentary and that's okay that's a
that's a different animal but movies are
always the best ones are at least going
to be about men and women and why they
can or cannot get along and why they
regardless of that why they have to be
together I still love it you have all
the scenes with or the great scenes with
Sarandon and Bull Durham and meanwhile
she's fallen in love with Tim Robbins on
the movie set and you don't even know no
I don't know and I think you probably
picked that up and it I was like I'm
like some dodo out there you know would
you have acted differently if you do the
taper in love no bathtub scene would
have been no I wouldn't but I tell you
what when you when you make that leap
with your your co-star your you don't
you no longer have the levers to say if
you think things are falling apart hey I
need a better effort out of you you know
and they go really you know you know so
you kind of lose that kind of little
high ground of like let's take care of
this movie because we're going to be
here every day and like if we really do
then we'll probably get together after
the movie you know and I mean and then
that's that's the way we'll know but no
I did not know about that one in and
they had a they had a pretty good thing
going for quite a while
kevin costner spent some time with us a
couple of days ago where we touched on a
variety of things he's been in so many
great movies a legitimate movie star and
I was able to ask him you know how this
second part starts here
do you guys we start with them you guys
asking a question right so more with
Kevin and the Dan has got a chance to
ask Kevin Costner questions the Danites
would like to ask you a question we'll
get to your movie as well we got Kevin
Costner here in the man cave all right
one question each and these haven't been
prior approval by me so don't embarrass
me here seaton go first is it more
difficult for you to make a movie or
write an album and record and you know
the album is harder I defend on my
bandmates and we co-write and I write
and a lot of times my songs I what it is
in my band I break all the ties I
decided what I was going to do and it
was my same thing here my deal to do it
and and the reality is because of sports
I make sure the cream gets to the top
and often it's not my song so making a
movie is is easier for me I couldn't
make a whole album I don't think that
that would add up to anything if I had
to do it by myself by the way we had
Dennis Quaid in a couple of weeks ago he
said you guys battled for roles in your
careers we did I think you know there's
you know the you know where white guys
were about six feet you know let's face
it let's break it down to what it really
is you know there's these things I mean
when I was trying to actually get into
this and I told you at the top that I
was in twenty eight till I got that
first check so who was sitting in front
of me didn't even have Mike it was Mel
Gibson it was it was Richard Gere it was
Michael Perret it was Ken wall it was
Sean Penn Timothy Hutton and and I you
know Nichols Gail I was thinking well
there's not going to be room and I just
I just kept on you know I just kept on
and there was a moment time I thought it
will be very difficult to jump because
their resumes are getting bigger and why
it's still a big big goose egg man
Paulie you're a question for KITT I want
to ask you about a night shift that you
were an extra in one of my favorites
movies but we're not going
go there because it's if you were on a
desert island headed by Maya you get two
questions okay but uh it was a nice
shift you were just saying you weren't
you an extra yeah yeah I was have an ex
oh yeah so I don't need to answer that
dumb dumb thing come on
all right if you were on a desert island
and if you run a desert island for the
rest of your life had to bring one of
your own movies and that's the only
thing you could watch what would you
bring up your movies uh might be a open
range you know I didn't really
understand right away Danny when you
said what do they say to you out there
but one of the things I get like from
real high up wriggle like a big western
western well that's what they won huh
that's what they want that's what they
want all right were you in that bathtub
were you in that bathtub with Sarandon
yeah well we would have bathtub I said I
was okay he was in it did you get more
publicity from The Big Chill by not
really being in it I did then if you
would have been the body the cadaver
there and you know that was my decision
to not do press in fact there was a big
movement for me to do press they said
Jesus this movies taken off you were in
that movie this is time to catalyze and
I just felt like no I'm going to have my
moment and I got a feeling they'll be
more interesting when I do in fact some
guy wrote a very scathing thing me in
Boston and said you know I tried to find
this Kevin Costner and he did oh it was
like a two paragraph thing three four
and he did a time time time or four four
days he tried to get a hold of me and he
goes and the guy wouldn't talk to me
he's not going to be nothing but he went
after me because of I wouldn't talk
about the movie that I wasn't in well
you you're dead yeah like you're I was
it it's just you don't it's a sports
they don't even show your face it's a
sports thing yeah you don't go I wasn't
on the team you know it's like when a
guy's injured it's really hard to take
your World Series ring you know you're
on the team but you know it's like you
know it's hard to take that ring I mean
the the the the Cowboys are gonna have a
good thing where they go I don't know
that would be a hard ring for Tony Tony
Romo
to put to put on because he's been such
a important part of that franchise and
he deserves it but him as a player
knowing that he's still a player they
always he's a really good player that
ring won't mean as much to him because
you know you got a play I want to talk
about the movie it's hidden figures it's
in theaters January 6th you're al
Harrison director of NASA space program
yeah and you have three african-american
women who are at NASA at the time yeah
and they're helping put John Glenn into
orbit yeah what happens is you know one
of the charming things about it can you
say charming in a mad cat and a man cave
yeah I don't think you can it feels a
little weak doesn't it but you know one
of the things that caught me when I
started reading the script because keep
in mind I read these scripts and no one
else knows what that when I read field
of dreams no one else knew what this
movie was I read at my couch and I
thought I got a secret I you know when I
go Bull Durham I I got a secret I read
these certain movies and I go I think
this movie can live for a long long time
when I started reading hidden figures it
dawned on me in one of the first scenes
or so that the people that did the math
were called computers long before your
computers mmm they were they had they
they had that name that's how they were
referred to so I thought that was a
interesting little piece of business but
you know I didn't know this story and I
think probably without you know getting
so far to the movie this we're talking
about really gifted people we're talking
about the girls you wanted to sit next
to in school up in to your left so you
could maybe see the paper there paper
yeah you know they usually hold in their
law but I guess one of the really the
thing about NASA the thing about this
country the thing about sports and I go
back to sports a lot is that was the
cream supposed to get to the top best
players supposed to play there's no
economic thing going on here and in the
case of hidden figures these women were
really smart and one of them was so
smart that when John Glenn who we all
know about because of history says I'm
not going unless the girl says I can go
and I go which girl and he goes the the
girl that I said which girl he goes a
smart girl
not the black girl not the cute one not
the white why not the smart one and the
idea that the cream got to the top and
John Glenn would get in that capsule and
go and put his life on the line for some
girl who did it longhand those kind of
things I like and you got the caster's
great yeah I mean these women are great
you got big names to be in this movie
yeah Octavia did black or white with man
so she was you know always fun for me
too Roger Henson yes exactly
you know Janelle Monae mm-hmm yeah look
at you what's next after this I gotta
make a Western - Western Kevin and maybe
get back in the tub with surrender it
were you in a tub look I can't Justin I
can't kiss a towel right here in New
York okay the movie that your kids love
watching is there one that stands out
that your kids yeah it's a mixed bag for
my older set I have you know I've got 30
29 28 and 9 6 & & 7 be light they like
Fandango you know they like they like
perfect world so it's a that's a mixed
bag there yeah it is yeah do you ever
stop by and just watch your own movie
once last time you did it no I
accidentally accidentally yeah and you
know the dog hears it before I do the
dog hears you all he knows the boys
until I kiss before I do it's the truth
it's the truth uh well good luck with
the movie thank you great to have you in
the man cave you didn't get the last two
cautions
all right McLovin your question I swear
I'm not making this up you stole my Big
Chill question but I was just gonna
state that Fandango is underrated loved
that movie
yeah all right but wait how did you find
out you weren't in big till by the way
will you watch a director called me and
he said look this has happened sometimes
it's the way I'm looking at it it's not
going to make it but he says I'm gonna
make this up to you I'm gonna put you in
a western Silverado
he didn't he didn't know the movie he
was going to make at that time but
that's a sports guy I'm gonna make it up
to you I like it I'm gonna make it up to
you and it's like you go and you know so
I didn't wilt like a daisy I wasn't I
didn't feel bad I felt like that was an
honorable thing a very difficult phone
call but I knew my career started with
that movie regardless of whether I
appeared in it or not you need to kind
of know what the moments are in your
life whether the world gets to see it or
not you know when the shoe drops and you
think you're on your way and I was on my
way when I did that movie
Fritzie final question movie role you
didn't get that devastated you the most
and the role you most regret passing on
but yeah I really wanted to do
Schindler's List I thought for a moment
I wanted to direct it it wasn't going to
be directed at first I was told it's
Steven wasn't going to direct it I went
after it and also you know I talked to
Steve and he goes I think it needs work
I said I think it's really perfect he
goes well I think it needs a little bit
more and then he ended up directing it
and you know he did a really beautiful
job but I I said well I'd still like to
play Oskar Schindler and and he said
well you know I'm I said could I read
for it and I've never told this story
okay this has never been told ever and
and I said and he goes well I'm thinking
I said look at I'll fly out and I'll
read for you so I got a bald cap and I
came and I came to his apartment up in
the kitchen he had a little camera and I
tried to play Oskar Shindler for him I
auditioned for him because I wanted to
be in it I felt like it was a really
important movie and I didn't get it Liam
Neeson got it and but I tell that story
simply because you know whatever act or
whatever people think your position is
in a world when you want something you
humble yourself and you go out and get
it you know you don't kowtow to anybody
but it's not too much of me to go put on
a ball cap and say I can play this guy I
didn't get that so a lot of people think
that dumb move flying across the country
kind of humiliating wasn't it I don't
see it that way so
that's a that's a true story in his
kitchen here in New York and I walked
out thinking man I'm a dumb kid I didn't
get it but you know what I thought I
thought you know in sports you go and
you try and you walk on and there are
people that don't develop in high school
don't even develop in college and
they're playing in the pros well you
have to get to the plate to get a hit so
you went to the plate
you go to Spielberg's apartment yeah you
took your cuts yeah I wanted to direct
that I wanted to act and I just worked
myself right out of that movie
the movie is hidden figures Kevin
Costner plays alan harrison director of
the NASA space program in theaters
January 6 thanks for joining us thank
you guys they appreciate the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience
[Music]